ein
wieder soweit bereit eure hier zählt
auffordern die sich ordentlich an
stellen müssen denn spätestens nach
diesem video werden sie umgehend
verlassen wollten meine lieben freunde
ich da welche die bedeuten was könnte
ich an halloween sein meine freundin ja
das wäre echt gruselig nicht weiter
halbe minute sind in diesem video nicht
läuft schon wieder klatschen durch mein
zimmer an was denkst du gerade daran wie
es wäre dich zu küssen ensuite und was
machst du so ich trinke dutzend über der
kloschüssel einfach mal mitten ins herz
gestochen wie weit es eigentlich afrika
von uns entfernt nicht weit wir haben
einen afrikaner in der schule und er
kommt jeden morgen mit dem fahrrad okay
wir haben neuen tiefpunkt erreicht als
nächstes bekommt ein whatsapp user hier
die nachricht ich will dich herr timo
die daraufhin schreibt dann der benutzer
du willst mich fragezeichen dann sende
eine sms mit ist klar die 22 68 22 und
bekommst den klingelton träumen weiter
gratis auf dein handy warenkorb von
einem komplett anderen planeten kommen
allerdings nun zu einigen nachrichten
die von müttern auf whatsapp geschickt
wurden und ihr wisst ja die eltern mit
whatsapp umgehen können wir
beispielsweise hat die mutter die
nachricht gesendet du hast dein telefon
auf dem küchentisch liegen gelassen das
ist intelligenz ganz
allerdings direkt bei whatsapp
nachrichten von der mutter uns war hier
die maden geschrieben kannst du mir von
unterwegs erdbeeren mitnehme ist ja eine
komplett normale nachrichten da wird man
es normalerweise antworten die sache ist
dass sich hier die mutter
er hat sich was wenn's gartenpforte aber
weit so lustig ist bleiben wir direkt
bei den whatsapp chats mit der mutter
und zwar schreibt hier die mutter deine
wunderbare tante ist gerade gestorben
ein plan warum die leute dahinter
schreibt vance eine traurige nachricht
ist oh mein gott was ist daran lustig
das ist nicht lustig wie kommst du
darauf filme mama heißt laughing out
loud also laut loslachen 1
ich dachte das heißt lots of love ich
hab das allen geschickt
als nächsten mama whatsapp chat
ich diesen heraus und zwar schreibt ja
eine mutter geschirrspüler ausgeräumt
hausaufgaben gemacht zimmer gesaugt und
da der sohn nicht antwortet schreibt sie
dann einfach papa und ich haben
beschlossen die nächsten monat ein auto
zu kaufen
omg wirklich danke nein wollte nur
wissen ob top oder nachrichten lief gute
taktik mama jagd als abschluss für diese
mama whatsapp chat fans habe ich diese
nachricht rausgesucht
spieltag ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch
jetzt aber meine mom schickt locker auch
so viele matches mit jeder nachricht
überall hässliche menschen egal wo man
hinschaut wird schon mal wieder im
spiegel labyrinth hat er sitzt tief
schatz mir gehts heute schlecht ich habe
kopfschmerzen und ich wollte mit dir
shoppen gehen habe extra geld zur seite
geht schadet sie hat mir spaß gemacht
ich auch dass so eine richtige gold
digger freude als nächstes kommen wir zu
einem etwas traurigeres chat verlauf und
zwar schreibt hier eine freundin schatz
betrügst du mich und ihr freund
beantwortet wieso ich will jetzt alle
also meine schuhe sind die treppe
runtergefallen und was war daran so laut
ich hatte sie noch an
also du bist mit deinem schon die treppe
runtergefallen wolltest du schon immer
eine 300.000 euro bands fahren ja
wolltest du jeden tag bis zu 100 mit mit
leben ja dann bewirb dich heute noch als
busfahrer wirklich dieses format ist
wirklich menschlich sind ziemlich
abstoßen ich kann griechisch italienisch
und chinesisch sprechen nein essen
das hätte auch von mir kommen können was
ist dein größter wunsch sich zu küssen
wenn es regnet deiner das ist nie regnet
örtlich wieder beende meine lieben
freunde werden euch dieser vierte
episode ocz vertex gefallen hat dann das
unbedingt einen daumen hoch unter diesem
video jeder schreibt wurde die
kommentare ob ich nächste woche einen
fünf tagen landen soll und abonnieren
falls sie noch keinen teil der luchs
usaid und ich habe doch eine kurze
ankündigung denn ich werde gleich ab 8
uhr einen live stream machen auf tape.tv
strich laser luca ich werde movistar
planet spiel nicht wer auf youtube
videos reagieren ich werde fragen
beantworten und anderen komischen
schwarzen machen also scheide gleich ab
8 uhr auf tape.tv schriftsteller dogan
und jetzt kommt das
[Musik]